testing testing hi I'm now in the
countryside of England at a place with
boat blocks Jesus brought me here but
he's off in the bushes so I'm going to
show you a move that I actually can't do
very well but it's come up because
there's sea for my part on that you know
I'm a big fan of and then that there's
sea anti-spin - bye - bye - fountain
which I quite like there is also the
aunty spin floor by for fun um which I'm
not all that good at but it's a pretty
simple move to understand I've been
recently making videos about the the 4x4
corkscrew which is greatly doing the
things like the matrix you can also take
the 4x4 corkscrew and if you simply
stand up with it and get it behind you
you can turn it into a 4x4 fountain I
know a windmill a 4x4 or window which
honest ollie
looks kind of awkward and bugling
compared to a regular windmill so it's
not something I would ever do on its own
but if you start it at your right ear
and finished it at your left here and
then exaggerate that motion that will
become your ante spin 4x4 fountain which
I can't do well but what I'm curious is
if any of you can or I'll put it out
there as a challenge to see who can
first do a video and post it of a really
smooth 4x4 in t-spin fountain because I
think it probably could look really cool
iced I have yet to put enough time into
it so that's the move that's the
challenge a smooth fluid and good
looking a teaspoon for before fountain
who gets it first
[Music]
we're saying frame you wooden frame yeah
that's always the the really interesting
to watch something what you don't like
yesterday you workplace it is depth of
yeah no edgy face that's quite and press
over there you say something hi I'm just
really curious how quickly your voice
drops off as I yeah it's really it's an
incredibly area sense of Mike your voice
drops off very quickly as I step away
[Music]